it is right right I'm casual and
relating with you hey hey what's up
fellas
dan cyber here I'm coolin we're related
yeah we're you know chillin on a couch
sure there's a camera pointer that's
what you know we're just we're in the
room with you guys we're just hanging
out what you do we were in the room with
you guy yes good check out the call of
duty black ops three story trailer I
mean if you're still with us I could do
it blood and gore drug reference intense
violence but yeah the Biebs
we wanted a perfect future and [ __ ] we
got it I wanted to be a killing machine
and they made me one one of the perks of
being blackops is having access to the
latest experimental weaponry we've got a
bit of hardware inside your head is
called a direct neural interface your
mind truly is your greatest weapon my
brothers have gone dark but nobody knows
just how far
I don't think these people volunteered
I've got to change the chaos as deep as
it goes the last important operation at
this station is John Taylor steam the
people who did this are traitors they're
going to continue to help the enemy we
need to fight back but when I look at
the hard truth I may not want to come
back when she calls visually one of
their seats they tend to bury bodies
right along with him
Oh
were tailors team killed our people I
don't know how much of the real Taylor
is left
you don't know what this will do
oh I can feel it taking over
not even my mind is safe
No
I still enjoy do you hear me don't
understand I'm taking us home that
Christopher Meloni yeah that was
Christopher Meloni game by loaded middle
and you can nuketown bonus nap heroine
loves their nuketown dude was it tense
you know I got me thinking like why do
people people know I'm not really a
gamer and I'm like why people always ask
me to check out these [ __ ] trailers
and then I watch them and I'm like okay
I get it these are like the cinematic
trailers yeah they're [ __ ] worth it
so you're watching yeah they though that
were [ __ ] dark as hell there's like
some intense [ __ ] I think of video games
that had this incredible ability to like
pull you into the cinematic world that
when you're doing the gameplay you still
feel like you're part of that cinematic
world they call it duty I feel like they
have these awesome cinematics and great
sequences but when you go to the
gameplay you're kind of just into the
gameplay at that point it's not really
the story that's affecting you at that
point yeah you know it's being in the
action and yeah feeling like you're part
of a war zone yeah wait are we on the
same page on the same page I'm trying to
say that would call of duty I don't ever
really get that vibe where I'm like this
is awesome story awesome of cinematic
effects but then when I'm playing the
game I don't feel like I'm aware of the
bigger picture oh okay we're saying the
same thing differently but my idea is
like the story does feel very usually
very disconnected from like the mission
because I'm like when I play Metal Gear
Solid the gameplay is a million times
more intense because I'm so invested in
this story with Call of Duty I feel like
I get it I'm like cool story but then
there's the gameplay but I don't really
feel like it's you ball tunnel vision
because you're like you have a ton of
dude shooting at you're just like I need
to get I need to get I get need to get
to there and so you just kind of blast
your way through and then arrive at end
of mission get cinematic thing that sets
up the next tunnel vision sort of thing
there's a lot of dark themes in it that
I really do enjoy you know like a lot of
it was pretty much about
um well death looking at this versus
other Call of Duty's the color scheme it
sounds really weird to talk about but
like back when ecology is really
becoming popular very Brown mmm-hmm it
was very like single like one color very
time not really bland but it's just dirt
and rubble and all that stuff but this
one feel like just like red it's such a
more prominent color I hope this doesn't
come out very pretentious but like you
could definitely get a different effect
and feel with like how like red and
blood and like well yeah death is
oriented in all this how the world is
just that of death now man violence
meanwhile I don't know what the [ __ ]
going on this is bad guys I know exactly
what's going Cody oh yeah um the main
guy who's like given the speech is his
wife was you know had an affair with
someone in Iraq and Afghanistan Taliban
am I going to know all I know is that
you you volunteered to become a robot
man and now someone's taking over mines
and you need to go shoot them
yeah it's universal soldier but in the
future they do however have Christopher
Meloni Christopher Meloni
he was one of my favorite actors I love
him he's a great he's one of those
under-recognized character actor role
totally i remember watching him in law
and order and then watching him in a
Harold and Kumar and I'm like those are
two very different or uh hot American
wit or wait out Americans yeah that one
yeah me woman that weights okay thinking
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it subscribe
and become thing way to bring it home
encore and out of ten some word that
makes you feel like you're special okay
and check out dance channel and become a
cyber not I'm a I'm a
right at 2:00 we become ratatouille or a
right to - oh right - Joey Ryan right a
tutti Adrien nuke you guys are so
freaking awesome can I please get a
shout out sure Adrien nuke I once knew
your mom in the face let me tell you man
she can take up pounding and a throat
boy i nuke the [ __ ] out of her face
after I you know blew up from my penis
my penis blew up she put a seat forward
dynamite underneath my balls and hit
that button and my balls blew up all
over her face she nuke me man
don't try a say is your mom was giving
me a [ __ ] and she blew off my penis
oh oh I was wondering why you were not
dead it what makes me feel so
uncomfortable
yeah as I enjoyed it I like the pain I
should move a dick route there mama said